yeah it just means a lot see I can't
lose these are your legs they look like
don't even [ __ ] go with your body
that's crazy dude no I'm not saying
you're old what I think you're a
nice-lookin I just think that it seems
crazy to have legs like that I also want
to tell people on about my obsession
with the next generation star drug yeah
is it good or bad obsession it's a grape
is obsession and if you haven't seen
Star Trek next generation there's a
there's an episode I want you to see
called the inner light season 5 second
to the last episode 2 or 1 it's a
one-hour one it's one of the greatest
sci-fi episodes I've ever seen it'll
change your life guys so please watch
what's your top 5 movies before we go
top 5 movies Bridges of Madison County
dream team really yeah James good
Michael Keaton yeah that's a good movie
Christopher Lewis yeah dream team Lloyd
Lloyd Christopher Lloyd yeah Christopher
Lewis is this lady I know that married
that man and Christopher Lewis and he
was a [ __ ] okay whatever
what else uh my favorite movies are the
Patriot obviously you know you know you
know isn't that Mel Gibson and Kirk Fox
the Fox is in it how great is that
that's great he's the best
he's the best of it yeah yeah so that
I'm watching that movie in the theater
and go that's the guy that works at the
tennis shop that buy my house
Finding Neverland I like and he's their
eclectic weird movies bro are they yeah
and this generally people go all
Apocalypse Now or you know something
like that
Godfather Godfather yeah I also like
that other movie frequency with Dennis
Quaid and have you seen that one
no we finds an old radio and he's able
to talk to his father who's who died Oh
ghost what was the one where they were
like little people during your there
inside the body oh I know what it is
it's called Honey I Shrunk the Kids
there was one where Martin Short gets
into a little tiny Sh
no he gets into a little spaceship what
is it no sometimes that's a voyage they
go inside the body and now he has to
live inside somebody's like
streams interfaces well intercept
interspace is it good it sounds bad
pretty bad but I like it yeah yeah
it sounds pretty bad what is the movie
you guys like to watch together well my
top 5 probably you have you see an old
boy yeah
the Korean Won it's not that great yeah
the Korean Won is that where they're all
fighting in a soul that's battle really
yeah yeah saw that but also [ __ ] [ __ ]
head
I didn't say that oh you're not gonna
like it
oh that's not the movie I said ok I
don't watch it what I'm saying to you
white is watch it ho ho I will try and
watch it I've seen the advertisements it
doesn't look that great there's a
troubled long-haired Japanese guy
outside of a [ __ ] lot of like bright
lights and he has on a jacket that's
kind of like disheveled that is kind of
true yeah name the rest of mole boy
Paris Texas Paris Tech Old Yeller I'm a
sober Old Yeller anything with Akira
Kurosawa yeah I like Rushmore on my top
that's good he said it anyway thanks for
listening to another episode of tire
belly um tiger bone is a delicacy is it
yeah what is it what's in it
Tiger belly an actual Tigers belly
yeah there's no [ __ ] way anyone's
eating a tiger oh yeah because they're
solitary creatures too it's like no they
are solitary anyway thanks for listening
to another episode of tiger belly go to
Ridge wallet comm / what / 9 9 promo
code Tiger belly promo code Tiger belly
[Music]